today I'm going to share with you a
creative way that's proven proven way to
be able to get an appointment with any
body you want
I'm Patrick many of your hosts of ie
team and we clear in today's episode was
inspired by a webinar I did for a
company called courier ilysm they're
very actually very interesting company
that they're trying to help people go
from having a job to become an
entrepreneurs and this this month's
episode it was dedicated to graduate
students coming out of college you're
getting your degree what do you do next
to land a job somewhere and the audience
was 9,000 people and I shared with them
I said if you want to get that one job
where you want to work for this one
company how do you get in front of the
CEO for the CEO to say you're creative
you're different to schedule that
appointment with them right and there's
a lot of different creative ways of
doing this I'm simply sharing one of
them here with you today and here's how
it works it's very simple I think the
biggest challenge with sales I've worked
with a lot of salespeople my career the
biggest challenge with sell is too many
salespeople are too vanilla it's just
too predictable like everybody else or
nothing about you is unique or creative
your approach people like a different
kind of an approach and this is one of
many ways to be a creative to be able to
get together with the person that's very
difficult to meet with so how do you set
up that meeting how do you get together
with that difficult that well of a CEO
for you to meet with that that
challenging person that you want to
potentially could be a client for you
your pharmaceutical sales you want to
meet with them you're into insurance
financial services there's a client you
want to meet with this way I'm sure it
worked 90% at a time it came through for
me 90% of the time you work for me so
let me share with you what you need for
this to take place first of all the
first thing you need to do is you need
to make a list of the people you want to
use this method on and you want to kind
of have fun with this make a list of
different people ceos that you want to
meet with a client whatever it could be
make a list of the seals once you have
the CEOs you need a box you need a box
to a put what I want to tell you to put
on the box you'll need to get
yourself a box in the box the third
thing you need to do you need to put a
shoe in the box
stay with me here you put one chute not
a pair one shoe in the box then you take
out the letter and you write a
handwritten note here's what it sounds
like
dear mr. CEO I want to have the
privilege of introducing myself to you
and potentially having the opportunity
to work for your great firm the reason
why I have a shoe in the box is to
represent that I have gotten one foot in
the door please
meet with me so I can get the second
foot in the door as well I hope you can
appreciate my sense of humor and
creativity sincerely your name when that
seals gatekeeper gets this box the first
thing she's going to do is a laugh
because they determine what's trashed
she's going to look at this crack up and
say CEO you got to see this I think you
got to get together with them and CEOs
like myself I run a firm myself as well
with a thousand agents we like working
with people like that they will tell
their assistant to call you and schedule
a visit to meet with you one-on-one so
now let me tell you what not to do the
donts the donts of what doesn't work
few things to think about one I suggest
you putting basic shoes stilettos don't
work if you put stilettos in there they
may get the wrong idea so don't do
stilettos - if it's smelly shoes it
definitely will not work you cannot put
used smelly shoes three if they are
smelly shoes and you're pretty creative
and you say I'm going to spray some
cologne in it to make it smell better
this works in junior high school it does
not work as an adult ok so make sure you
not spraying it either and if you don't
do those things you send this box to
them you will be so surprised with the
respond you get from people and how many
people will be willing to meet with you
on a one-on-one basis so I got three
challenges for you one if you want to
see the webinar that I did for courier
lism it's called grant
and swag or if you got somebody that
just graduated from college and they
want to get some valium what to do to
land that job you can click on the
description the webinars click it'll
take you to the courier loads and
website and you can see all the detail
when I give that live presentation to
subscribe to this channel and three I
want you to share this video with
somebody you may know that can use this
method to land that job that they want
to get with that company that position
they want to have or to be able to have
the meeting with that one client they
always wanted to have that's my message
of the week too and I look forward to
getting your comments on the bottom
button of what you're doing
you could about to get me good but first
let me take a selfie hey you know what I
was told the other day somebody told me
I look at like I look like an asura king
it's like a Puerto Rican and a Syrian
combined so Puerto Rican and a Syrian
how would you say that the Syria is
Tavian sana
today I'm gonna share with you Oh what I
just had Cheesecake Factory let me get
that drink Mario I'm Patrick this is
that happy again
ah did it happen again